hey it's evan i'm doing another one of
my fiverr gigs where i'm reviewing
somebody's website and this one is
tripadvisorgenius.com so here's the
website here's what it looks like i love
this home
graphic here we manage men and defend
your tripadvisor reputation and profile
so it's a clear value proposition that
makes sense
the layout could be a lot better uh it
doesn't look super professional you can
get somebody on odesk to help you out
99designs.com there's a lot of people
you can get to help you out just to make
this look a little more professional it
looks like we're using some kind of uh
template here which is great i don't
know what this is here at the top this
google bf whatever thing here at the top
that looks a little weird
you're using a professional template but
then all your graphics
are not great
but you have a clear value proposition
this could be so much better so let's
look into it a little bit more and see
what we can do
digging down here so very cluttered lots
of things happening
you're talking about managing many
defending tripadvisor's reputation
profile great i love that
then here we're talking about what is
tripadvisor and
you know all their great stats about how
big they are the people who are going to
hire you are the ones who already know
about trip advisor and the ones who have
a problem they have a pain and they need
help you're going to help them you're
not going to get the guys who have no
idea what trip advisor is and convince
them that they need to have a good trip
advisor profile and pay you hundreds of
dollars every month to make it happen
right so i would take all of this out i
would focus in on the people who already
have tripadvisor pages and want to make
it better they have a problem right they
have negative reviews they're not
getting ranked whatever their challenge
is take all of this stuff out
all of this here this all needs to go
then i want to know about again the pain
lead here with the pain
so what is the pain why do people hire
you
what's the main challenge that they have
and they hire you for that's got to be
front and center i get the value prop
now make me feel pain and then solve it
for me that's what's missing here
i don't really know what you do
so okay you help me manage men and
defend that's great and then
none of this really talks about exactly
what you do
to help me
so that's what i'm worried about that's
what you need to make clear
put it front and center
i love the shield logo here this is
great uh the concept is great the actual
picture here is not great again i'd
invest
in having somebody at 99designs or odesk
help you actually make a really
professional logo but this concept is
great because you have the shield that
represents something that's strength
it's defense and that's really what you
do so this is this banner here is
amazing but could be so much better the
messaging is there
the concept is here but the execution is
really poor so that's what you need to
fix up and that's that's the hard part
making it look good is a lot easier than
coming up with the messaging itself
so definitely work on fixing that up i'd
like to see some testimonials here
uh i don't really see any testimonials
here people who you've helped it'd be
great to see that somewhere again have
some social proof to say hey you're not
just some brand new startup you've had
success you've helped companies overcome
their their problems on tripadvisor
i don't know people would be willing to
share you know their name ideally they
share their name they share their
company if they've actually been wronged
right you're not starting some kind of
scammer service they've been wronged and
you help them overcome that that's
something they should be happy to share
they get some exposure
you have a quote here there's a mythical
law of nature three things we create
most in life i don't know how this
relates to what you're selling at all so
this is confusing to me
okay let's dig deeper on another page
uh what we do so this is what i want to
know what do you do
so
this is starting to get better
so brief list of some of the beneficial
services we offer to evaluate clients
again the layout could be better the
pictures could be a little better
instead of using these little stock
cartoon pictures
this is getting a lot better this should
be more on the home page not all of this
but a little bit more take all of that
junk at the top
about what is tripadvisor and start to
replace it with the pain points and then
what it is that you do this is a lot
better and it's great that you're
complying with their use of the terms of
service you're not doing fake reviews
you're not doing spam
this is great i'm liking this page a lot
more again
i try to have some testimonials put that
here this isn't helpful for me
tripadvisor's latest survey results i'm
coming to you because i have a
tripadvisor problem i know tripadvisor
is great i want to get more results from
it and i want you to hire i want to hire
you to help me get there so all these
stats i take out and replace it with
testimonials of people that you've
actually helped out and if you haven't
helped anybody out yet then start
helping them out and so i'll help you
for free if you give a testimonial
because that's what you need here to
build some social
let's go to uh packages so i'm
interested i want to buy
wow this page is a mess
this this page i look at it and i'm
confused there's colors everywhere i
don't know where to focus this place is
all over the place
i would expect
so there'd be some kind of setup fee
some kind of monthly fee that makes
sense
business size
it's just the way it's displayed is not
great you really need to work with the
designer to make this stuff pop a lot
more because you're going to lose people
somebody hits this page they have to be
really really interested in what you're
selling to to weed through all this
stuff because it's really hard on the
eye
business size
so these are i guess hotels it's my
hotel medium hotel i mean there's lots
of other companies on on trip advisor
too
here we get to some restaurant
attraction tours other services so that
should be front and center
right you should say
what kind of business do you run here
and let them click and then show them
packages because if i come here and i
just look at this
and i say well i'm a tour company i'm
not a hotel i may bounce not knowing
that buried deep on this page there's
more information that can help me
so this is great and that you have your
setup free and look like you're you're
charging people up to 900 a month
right like nobody's going to sign up for
900 a month service without really
knowing what you do and seeing some
testimonials about how great you are so
you got to really work on that messaging
there
and let's look at one more faqs
uh so q a coming soon again you know you
want to you want to fill up your website
you don't want sections of your site
that say under construction
we've got a spelling mistake here
pull a raise
jerk back or email your questions okay
so we gotta
we're gonna fix up our branding uh spell
check your site before you put it live
nobody's to spend 900 a month with you
and you have typos all over your site
so fix that up i mean i don't know what
stage if you're actually selling this
yet it's good to have a guarantee
your logo here again needs to work um
you have the watermark of the place that
you got it from so you need if you're
gonna stick to this shield go buy the
photo like it's five bucks or ten bucks
whatever it is buy the photo make it
look nice
and if you create a strong brand message
when people come to your site they feel
like these guys know what they're
talking about if i if i just hit this
page and i see
spelling mistakes incomplete content and
a logo that that has a stock watermark
on it i'm i'm gonna leave
this doesn't tell me i'm gonna spend 900
with these guys every month i like
the concept i think there's a huge pain
that a lot of entrepreneurs face who've
been
given a negative trip advisor school i
go to tripadvisor and i look at the
businesses there when i'm traveling
and so if you can actually help these
guys that's a huge service
but what you're presenting here needs to
be done in a much more attractive way
in a way that makes me believe
that what you can do is actually going
to work because now i have my doubts i
have strong doubts
it looks a little amateurish
and it doesn't take a lot of work to
make this look really good to make it
pop and to make people
want to dump 900 a month with you and
see that it's gonna work
so those are my quick thoughts
uh good luck and for everybody who's
watching
you know it's great to have a great
message but you have to your your the
way you reflect it has to come across
right it's got to look good
or you're not going to get people
spending big dollars with you if you're
trying to charge a premium price
your website has to look like a premium
offer
for those of you watching if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below and i'll do more similar videos
and if you have a thought about this
website or you have a question for your
own business please leave in the comment
section below i always read those i love
seeing them come in thank you guys i'll
see you on the next episode
you